no but I'm not saying there's my my dad
used to work here while my family were
back home my dad wasn't present in their
lives every single day and I think
that's another big misconception that a
parent or a dad has to be at home every
single day it's a cultural thing is that
did it affect you and not having them
there all the time no no not at all and
I love my dad like my dad was an amazing
man an amazing father figure amazing
that's why I can't trash men because I
have so much respect for myself I don't
think it would have been better if your
dad was there a bit often you spent more
time
I'm just thinking about Pearl nothing is
that no no yeah my dad my dad was gone
my dad was gone a lot too and I'd say
like it did affect me like I yeah I mean
I would have been better if he was there
I still love him and I respect him more
than anything but like I I think it
would be dumb to say I didn't want my
dad around more
do you think he would have changed your
perspective on you because you said you
battle being traditional Western do you
think if your dad was there more that
you'd be a lot more traditional than
Western
um no I think the problem with me was
when I went to UNI and I came out of my
traditional or my culture bubble the
bubble so I think that bubble protected
me for so long and I wish I stayed in it
a bit longer because the trauma only
came when I thought oh let me experience
a bit now I'm like can I just say this
do you think your dad being present in
your life when you were growing up would
help you manage your situation right now
with your husband better because he
would have been able to advise you or
even now I don't know what your
relationship is at now but he would be
able to guide you or even have an impact
on you in a way that would allow you to
manage the situation better
I don't know I feel like I'm managing
the situation well compared to what
Society will tell me because there's a
lot of people that will tell me why even
investing any more time or why even
allowing this Dynamics because a lot of
people say OH Close book and rush out
yeah that's why girls give the worst
advice yeah I
I would say you're managing it well
unless you're still with him can I just
no it's like it's it's not you can't
it's like
that's not getting that's like like
failing a test and seeing you guys no
when I say managing it well I'm saying
about I'm respecting his values or views
in where he is in life I'm respecting
that he's not ready to commit to the
marriage and children yet because he
feels like he can't be that responsible
no wait wait wait before that before
so right I'm so proud of you like we can
all see how much like you love your
daughter how much you're trying to make
this work like because life is hard you
know like no no no no no
she only got here she only got here
because she did she because before we
said yeah that ah women women said they
lack the truth in it your husband told
you the truth saying that I may
potentially want to step out on you yeah
and that's what started this whole
debacle of problems of relationship so
him being honest is kind of why you're
here isn't it initially it was the my ex
cheating that was the issue but you said
you had help for that trauma you said
you had that trauma no no that's
something I've gone in later like would
you say within the last year it does it
seems to me like you and your husband
split because of something that he might
do in the future yeah and that was me
looking back at myself saying I was the
fault of that and that was me taking it
are you now saying that as a young woman
that traditional is the way to go 100
thank you a hundred percent I'm I will I
Believe In traditional roles I believe I
just believe that this Society doesn't
enable that and a lot of my anger as
well even in my relationship was the
fact that I had to work and I had to do
things that a woman shouldn't
necessarily do because Society now is
too expensive can I just say that to the
society though can I just say that
traditional women always work they did
yeah
no no no no you asked your mama how she
worked she didn't leave the house yeah
exactly so we're doing the housework and
then more she's talking about career I'm
talking about Korea well I'm saying that
it all depends on how you see it no 100
and also if you and your husband
wouldn't it be better if you both got a
flat with three bedrooms and worked out
two separately that's the thing money is
the issue so if money wasn't an issue of
course we could have a mansion and we
could no I'm just saying is it is it
there it's liver pot then to live
together
yeah uh yes
we would
it's just easier for now because
obviously where we're not easier I'm
talking about cheaper is it cheaper to
live separately or is it would it be
cheaper to get together
it's just not a position we're at now
because we're only I've only just healed
could you just answer that yes or no is
it cheaper to live apart
it's cheaper to live together but
obviously if I'm not like I've only gone
through my counseling and having to
learn about myself in the last year and
a half that time I was alone if that
makes sense if I'd never done that I
would never have gone through counseling
or learn about myself and what I and
I've learned and I think the thing is I
had an amazing father figure I had an
amazing childhood with my dad and my dad
not being there he was there you know
him not being there for parts isn't
impacted me at all my relationship was
amazing there was other things that
happened when I was a child that made it
more difficult
if that makes sense yeah in me in my
longer lifelong marriage and I think
once I then went counseling for that I
then realized actually there was a lot
of me that had to heal before I even
took that step can I just give you a bit
of advice traditional women
don't listen to the female friends
traditional women that listen to social
media and traditional women don't get
easily influenced by outside forces and
I think that's what you're struggling
with so you can't balance it too because
I know you're saying that you're modern
and that you want to be traditional but
you're saying that these are what your
friends are telling you to do and this
is what this person is sending you to do
and this is what the internet's selling
to do and this is where your struggle is
against your traditional and your modern
but you said that traditional is the way
to go so it's gonna be easier just to
fade out all the models
okay listening to you I think that it's
admirable that you've been for what
you've been through and you went to
yourself to know where it is that you
went wrong I feel like the Social Media
stuff the friend stuff for me I'm
hearing her tell me that that is the
past that's what she did that got her in
this position now and I'm in my mind is
that moving forward
you've you've learned a lot from how
what you did wrong that I reckon that
when even if it's this guy if it's
another guy you're going to be a better
partner then you are before because now
what you what you believed what you knew
of relationships before was from social
media was from friends or whatever but
now you've experienced something
different so now you're more realistic
about your expectations that is where
the whole traditional thing comes from
because when I hear tradition for me
because I'm Nigerian like I think
culture that's why I understand you
saying that you know your dad not being
in the house didn't really affect you
because that is what this happens my
cousins are the same thing like it's
what if it's if it's what you're around
if it's if that's what you're
socializing to if that's the norm yeah
it's nothing that's it's not on to you I
mean I'm just gonna tell you how it
sounds it just sounds like a lot of
excuses to me
like it's just like this is right this
is why this is why this is why because
like like when you're saying oh it's
social media it's the culture it's this
it's that it's that it's like oh that's
that's why I did what I did it's like it
kind of takes away from accountability
when you're just blaming all these
things because
I know she's saying it's admirable that
you've got rid of it and that was in the
past and whatever I came late I
apologize for coming late
what year did you go Carnival
I moved on to Ladbroke Grove 2017. wait
let me just finish this Carnival PR is
this is it's just like this is instead
of just saying instead of just saying
being accountable and you know what I
wanted to go like it's like oh I lived
on this road it's like no okay so again
I don't see where the issue with
Carnival is again maybe because listen
to what I'm saying when I came here late
I didn't know when you went Carnival so
all I'm heard from you is that you've
had the cats in a year and a half so
that's what I'm asking you when did you
go because I wasn't here so I didn't
know right and even when I went Carnival
I'm a very standoffish person no one
will chat to me because my demeanor is
very like um so even me going Carnival I
dance if I dance with my friends it's my
girlfriends I'm dancing with no one else
I'm going for man I'll tell you that
right
I'm not going there
yeah can someone explain to why that
would be a bad thing exactly this is
what I mean also I understand you go I
understand you guys are Carnival for men
but we're all not the same people are
different can I just say something
differently
as a traditional
single parent with a child on the age of
five that's not looking no man that
wants to stay away from outside
influences that don't want to get
influenced by social media she shouldn't
be okay
I'm just going by what she said that she
is no and by what she said I can only go
by what she said that's why Pearl's
talking about the contradiction because
as far as I'm concerned if I was a
single parent or a five-year-old child
the only time I'm going Carnival is with
my child on a Sunday and we're going to
be home by like six o'clock in the
evening I will not as a single parent go
Carnival without my job
Carnival's not the place to have a break
it's like she's contradicting herself
the whole show and so you say one thing
and then you say another thing I don't I
really wasn't even probing like honestly
wait let me I'll I'll ask you a question
you'll tell a really long story and like
which is fine it's a podcast that's fine
but when you contradict yourself like
five times in the story and people start
asking questions like then you get
defensive and I wasn't telling her what
to do I said as a single parent I would
have gone Carnival I would have gone
Carnival I would take my child is what
I've done that's why that's what I see
we're indifference and I was a younger
single parent than you were yeah we're
in different errors obviously social
media came when I was about 16 even
before this is an excuse again
like like oh but it's the time like like
this is like your immediate response
with anything is like oh this is the
excuse it's like no I'm not making
excuses I'm saying I was battling what I
was battling then I'm still learning I'm
still like even now when I tell my
friends oh do you know what polygeny I
don't mind it a lot of my friends will
be like oh my God what are you talking
about some of them will be like actually
I get what you mean because a lot of
them have gone through the cheating back
and forth and all of that and they're
like you know what I I it's changed my
mindset so what I'm saying is where I am
now even now I'm still not who I want to
be fully because the more days pass the
more I do things even being a mother
even just working even everything else
the more I'm learning how much better is
being a traditional woman it's taken me
a lot longer only because I'm having to
learn that my mum's life was happier
than what I am how are you learning
just doing every single day the
difficulties of being a woman in the
21st century I don't find it difficult
how does that make you more traditional
living modern I'm not even more modern
I'm accepting that modern isn't the way
forward yeah but I want a man who is
going to be a traditional gender role
where yeah yeah but I mean we can want
what we want but only one in four men
only one in four women really get that
traditional role like most most women
work so like the majority women don't
get that like let's say like saying I
want to be a millionaire okay yeah like
how does how does that make you more
traditional no like what actionable it's
more me realizing how much the right
wing feminism shall I say or just that
movement itself has hindered women
because I feel like I want to now engage
in my feminine energy more and the more
I'm engaging in my feminine energy and
the more I'm realizing actually I don't
care if a man sleeps with tender girls I
don't want to sleep with 10 guys like
the more I'm realizing I'm not the the
same as a man in that sense the more
unhappy I'm getting my rebuttal when I
was younger was more because it was like
oh what if he could do it why can't I if
he does this why can't I now I'm
actually like no I'm being a feminine
woman I want to be have you practiced
that in a relationship like doing the
polygeny thing
uh not yet not yet yeah so so it's just
like that's not really that's saying
like I would accept it isn't really like
no it's because okay for example like my
husband now my ex or partner if he was
to approach me and say you know what I'm
ready to settle down but that is an
option I will 100 accept it